you guys ever have any stalkers you guys
are having any good experience with
stalkers
i feel like both you guys have had at
least one
i don't have my
miner i'm not famous i like like come on
stalk me i would love attention yeah i'm
a [ __ ] egotistical idiot
everybody [ __ ] stalks me i think they
stalk me and then i go hey you want to
get coffee and they're like what the
[ __ ] dude you're pretty pretty intense i
think i'm going to stalk tony hawk
in the 80s in the 80s there was a girl
that paid the front desk to tell her
which room i was in so that she could
get a room next to mine nice nice um and
then
and then what but
nothing happened
she did knock on my door one time and
then
like it was sometime through the weekend
she knocked on my door and then she did
come in for a little bit nothing nothing
happened but all of a sudden this
slamming on the door came
and i guess it was her boyfriend oh that
guy that knew the whole
scoop of what she was up to
i'm just i'm just like i didn't even
know that this girl had already done
this i found this out later yeah right
and then
the next day
uh i'm getting the elevator and the dude
i didn't know it was him because i
hadn't seen him and you all got in this
he goes in the elevator and he looks at
me and he's got a cast on no
and why what happened to me and he's
like sorry about slamming on your door
last night broke my wrist oh
idiot i was overreacting i'm sorry i was
like and he apologized yeah well i guess
he was drunk i feel sorry for that guy
that was a that was an odd one yeah i
was just sort of okay they don't i feel
like they're well yeah what you got you
got i kind of had that then yeah because
girls will try and sleep with me and
usually they just can and it's fine
but one time at a alice mania they had
this fight called the strip fight where
uh every 30 seconds we decide who won
the 30 seconds and uh the the person
that loses takes an item of clothes
clothing off until they're down to a g
string in pasties so i just go
regardless i go you lost you lost you
lost you lost
right now you're both naked fight
yeah so then they fought and that's kind
of the thing so one of the people you
know dm me that they're that i get
fighters you're not allowed to know how
to fight that's the whole point you're
supposed to i'm terrified what is it
like to fight and i go i'll hook you up
in a fight where you get a real fight
but you're not going to get really hurt
okay joe rogan might disagree but it's a
couple of shots yeah and if you look
like you're in trouble we just call it
we don't let you like bleed really cook
out yeah you can't be grilling them out
right so this girl's nice enough she
does the fight awesome fight she looks
great she's got a what i assume is a
boyfriend but it's like uh everyone has
a uh you're allowed to bring a coach or
whatever or just a plus one so you got a
man over there helping her out a little
later yeah so there's a after party and
i got this big room with all this
[ __ ] at the hard rock yeah and she's
hanging out and she's
asking if she can sleep with me
and um who's she asking me and i go i go
well katie
my wife i go she wants to sleep with me
she's like yeah whatever and i'm and i
go what about this guy who's this guy
she gets just my coach oh and i go oh
well then okay no problem and then i and
then she's hanging out and i look at him
and i'm like he is
obviously bummed oh and i go hey man
what's what's going on you're right over
there he's like you know she's just you
know
just been going out with the
with each other for like some amount of
years and i'm like what we broke up i'm
like but you're i'm like i'm so out of
this you guys need to spend time
together go get him a little gift
certificate or something i can't play
that game but yeah every now and then
somebody just tries to rain check yeah
get them well i like to feel like star
because some of my friends always get
stalkers and i'm like damn i can't get i
think soccer's is more of a sex thing if
you're good at if you do good sex
then i think you get a stalker you know
you mean somebody you've already had sex
with and it was so good that they just
keep
i feel like that's the only way it would
make sense like if you kinda are okay at
sex i don't think anybody's you know
smashing through your wings to get back
and hang out with you yeah
i thought stalkers you'd never messed up
nobody's getting a little more
mentally unstable and it's not but
something has to spark that stalk you
gotta you gotta light that up
a lot of times they think that whatever
whatever art you're doing whatever
whatever content you're creating is
speaking directly to them
all right i mean that that seems like
the more scary stalker not
hey i like you and i'm trying to get to
you
i i i guess i had a girl who left her
vax card on my window and they said she
wrote check me for covet on there
charlotte was her name
but i never had anybody like my friends
get the girls they're jumping over the
fence or yelling and they're throwing
stuff through the windows they're
showing up like you're talking about
groupies not stalkers
i i don't know these are the ones
they've had to call the cops
wow
not stalkers yeah so really
but i think they got to be sexually
motivated i don't think anybody's
[ __ ]
smashing through your living room window
to [ __ ] come watch an episode of uh
dexter new blood or something you know
i'm saying like i think you got to have
like a real
you got to have fused them up with some
cops it's an interesting theory i think
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you